[Music]
the wallstreet statue of a fearless girl
will stare down the charging bull for
months to come the little girl with
their hands on her hips won a permit to
spend another 11 months in front of that
iconic bronze bull now the roughly 4
foot statue has become a social media
sensation and a major tourist attraction
but the artist behind the bull claims it
alters the meaning of his work and
infringes on his copyright Tony Tecopa
is in lower Manhattan next to both
statues Tony good morning good morning
for decades this 7,000 pound bull has
dominated lower Manhattan all by itself
but check this out since March 8th it's
had to share this space with a little
girl who now has a lot of friends who
hope she stays right here staring down
the bull forever fearless girl began as
a temporary installation a stealth ad
campaign for a financial company hoping
to highlight the lack of women on
corporate boards but after weeks of
adoring crowds she now has a new permit
to stay put through at least February
2018 she spoke to the moment that sense
that women were not going to live in
fear artists christened viz Bell built
the statue bottom line of 2000 are
strong women are here but the fearless
girl's symbolic stare down with Wall
Street's charging bull has morphed into
a real world standoff they are
transforming illegally the message of
the bull Arthur piccolo is a
spokesperson for Arturo de Motyka the
Italian sculptor who made the bull as a
symbol of hope now this girl is
confronting this supposedly that looks
from a monstrous figure that's an
outrage to take a great work of art and
transform it back in 1989 the bull was
considered the outrage dropped illegally
onto a public street downtown piccolo
led the campaign to give the statue its
current home we want the girl gone it
would serve its purpose like nothing
else in what in front of the New York
Stock Exchange the New York Stock
Exchange represents most of those
companies that have problem with
equality she has clearly struck a nerve
she
become an overnight sensation New York
congresswoman carolyn Maloney and
thousands of petitioners online are
pushing to make the fearless girl's
message last forever possibly in this
very location what would you say to
people who think the bowl was fine on
its own and the girl changes the meaning
of that statue the world change owes and
women are here we're an integral part of
the business community and we're going
to be even more important tomorrow now
the financial firm that commissioned the
girl State Street Global Advisors
declined to comment on the controversy
or their hopes for the future of the
girl representatives of the bull
meanwhile say they're reviewing their
legal options
Gail alright Tony is it an outrage not
really
I think she's terrific I love her little
ponytail swinging I think it does but I
think it's great for both there's a
place for both there sorry she needs a
name I think yeah we can all agree that
we need more girls on Wall Street yeah
we can definitely agree on that and I
would never know if anybody that's Mia
or grace or Riley that looks like a
little nor their to me Tony thank you